Hallo Leute, immer außer der Reihe am Start, 12.52 montags, gut ich mein ich bin immer
daheim montags, nicht unbedingt daheim aber nicht auch bei der Arbeit, aber ich weiß
nicht wie das bei euch so aussieht, aber Arbeiten ist eh offerrated, cheapated, outdated, sind
wir uns einig oder? Ich muss gerade mal kurz gucken ob ich irgendwelche komischen Mails
gekriegt habe die letzten Tage, ich habe letztens eine Anfrage gekriegt auf Twitter,
hallo max FPS, let's do business, von irgendeinem China-Chinesen Ding, ja auf geht's, sofort
dabei, was für bescheuerte Anfragen krieg, was wollen die von mir, oh nein NordVPN ist
auch wieder am Start, die vergessen glaube ich, dass sie das letzte Mal nicht wollten,
weil ich gesagt habe ich lösche mein VPN-kritisches Video nicht, das haben sie irgendwie vergessen,
wobei ich glaube das ist einfach jetzt eine andere Agentur, das sind ja immer 100 verschiedene
Agenturen die die gefügt beauftragt haben, keine Ahnung, Arsch, achja ja, richtig, schau
wir mal, ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher was ich installiere, also ich habe jetzt hier
das Fall entweder, also erstmal der Grund, der Grund warum ich jetzt, also der Grund
warum ich gedacht habe jetzt ist mal wieder ein guter Zeitpunkt ist, also man hat mehrere
Gründe, das erste ist, weil man Jaro aktuell keine Architekt-Version mehr hat, also sprich
ich könnte den Kram gar nicht neu installieren, außer halt irgendeine fertige Version benutzen
mit Zeug drauf was ich nicht haben will, ok, und ansonsten weiß ich auch nicht was mit
man Jaro in letzter Zeit abgeht, keine Ahnung, so und ich habe jetzt zur Auswahl, entweder
wir machen Massive Fivehead Arch, by the way, direkt oder wir machen so was wie Endeavor
OS, ich tendiere aktuell zu Arch, by the way Umfrage, gut, ja wir können Umfrage machen,
ich mach ne Umfrage, ok, aber wir installieren auf jeden Fall minimal, also wir installieren,
also wir installieren entweder Minimal-Version, hier, Hallo, hier Download existiert nicht
mehr, ist outdated, Leute, der Download funktioniert, er legt das am Darkreader vielleicht, dass
der Download nicht geht, ok Leute, also der Download geht noch nicht mal, ah jetzt, null
installer, also wir machen Minimal-Installation, deswegen bin ich, nee wir machen keine Umfrage,
hast du schon das Arch-Install-Skript getestet, nee hab ich nicht, ich weiß, dass es das
gibt Arch-Installer, dass das irgendwie seit einem Jahr oder so gibt, das Ding hier, keine
Ahnung, ich würd's nach dem Wiki, ich würd's nach der Wiki-Anleitung machen und ihr werdet
es nicht glauben, aber ich meine, ich verwende zwar schon ewig Arch-based, ein Arch-based
Linux, aber ich habe noch nie Arch, by the way, den Archway installiert, das Arch-Skript
ist die neue offizielle Methode, also das da, oder wie, Arch-by the way, ja was, wir legen
erst, ok, also, also ich kenn nur das hier, Arch-Wiki-Install, ich kenn nur das hier,
das ist auch nicht, also ich hab das schonmal so durchgeguckt, das sah auch nicht super
kompliziert aus, aber, ok, also ihr meint, das Arch-Install-Skript ist the way, ich mein,
das hat 3,6K Sterne, also 3600 Sterne, das kann ja schonmal gar nicht so beschissen sein,
ja Moment, Moment, was ist denn das, wie soll ich denn bitteschön Pacman SS Arch-Install
machen, wenn ich noch gar keinen Arch installiert hab, achso, man muss einfach ne Iso runterladen
und Arch installieren, das probieren wir doch mal aus, wenn man sich bisschen mit Betriebssystem
und Linux auskennt, ist easy, ok, ok, also Iso, by the way, Arch-by the way, über BitTorrent
by the way, natürlich der einzige Grund BitTorrent zu verwenden 2022 um Linux Distribution runter
zu laden, sind wir uns ja einig, niemand würde je was anderes Usenet oder BitTorrent technisch
runterladen, anstatt über BitTorrent, Linux und, ok, no cup, netboot, netboot, poc, wir
machen netboot, auf gehts, warum soll ich das netbooten, das ist, dass ich das Iso nicht
runterladen muss oder wie, ach gut, ich hab keine Schmerzen mit das Iso runterzuladen,
ja man, ok, gibts da irgendeinen Host, jensgutermut.de, netcolon, ok, die hosten viel, Aachen, die haben
auch Zeug am Start, die TU Chemnitz, komm, die nennen wir jetzt, Arch-by the way, Iso,
ok, aber ich bin geneigt, tatsächlich mal das netboot Image zu verwenden, ach ne, das
ist kein Iso, das ist über, ja Moment, ich könnte einfach netboot x, y, z und das Ding
funktioniert, aber keine Ahnung, ich lade jetzt einfach das Iso runter und gut ist, ja,
klar, wer kennts nicht, ja, mein NAS hier daheim ist auch nur für Sicherheitskopien
und Backups und Linux Distributionen und so, wobei, jetzt no cup, ich hab auf meinem NAS
wirklich nix aus der Grauzone liegen, weil ich streame Musik nur noch übers Internet
mit Abo und ich gucke Filme eigentlich so gut wie 95% übers Internet, Streaming mit Abo,
jetzt ganz ohne, wirklich ganz ohne cup, das einzige, wo ich manchmal über irgendwelche
Streaming Seiten gucke, womit also nicht Abo ist, wenns halt bei mir was nicht gibt, sei
es nicht in der Sprache oder aber gar nicht, ich hab tatsächlich letztens irgendein Anime
über irgendeine Streaming Seite geguckt, aber das war schon seit langer Zeit mal das einzige,
wo ich nicht über irgendwie Amazon oder sonstige Sachen geguckt hab und das hat mich wieder
hart verstört, Leute, ich bin ja nicht der große Animegucker, also ich hab da nicht so
viel Plan von, aber es hat mich wieder hart verstört, ja, ich dachte, das gibt so ne 0815
Fantasy Story, die Story, also gar nicht schlecht, will ich gar nix sagen, nur das auf einmal
zwischendurch irgendwie perverse Dinger passieren so und so random einfach, aber gut, das muss
wahrscheinlich so sein, so, also legen wir mal ne VM an, dieser Desto, wieso, ist gut,
ich find alles hier drauf, überhaupt kein Problem, chat, wir haben es doch oft genug
schon gemacht, ihr sagt mir was und ich find's sofort, das müssen wir jetzt nicht wiederholen,
so, also Stream4M, die könnte man tatsächlich mal so langsam aber sicher löschen, die Stream4M,
weil das ist die Ur-Ur-Ural-Stream4M, die brauch ich gar nicht mehr und die Poggers4M
ist die neue, die würde ich theoretisch auch beibehalten, aber ich will mir ja was abgucken,
deswegen mach ich ne neue und kopier mir dann die Dateien rüber und lösche den alten Kram,
Gentoo, na, da hab ich kein Bock drauf, ja schon und machen wir das einfach mal, ich
leg mal ne neue vor allem an, hallo, ich hab mir eingebildet, man kann, man kann hier drüber
auch anlegen, ok, anscheinend, so hier, so, new virtual machine, ich hab übrigens noch
uralt, vor allem bei Workstation, aber mein Scheiß drauf, nicht dass ich da großartig
was geändert hätte, so, next, install later, achso, wir können die Installer-Disc schon
rein machen, arch, by the way, da ist der Installer, gut, Linux, osa osa Linux, das
ist die beste Distribution, 64-bit, arch, by the way, und nicht auf C-Doppelpunkt, sondern
auf C, da hab ich keinen Platz, auf E-Doppelpunkt, VMS, arch, by the way, oh, das ist gut, wer
nutzt noch x11, ich werd weiterhin x11 verwenden, weil ich E3 benutzen will, und das letzte
Mal, als ich mir Sway angeguckt hab, war das Paints-Champ, Dark, bestes MMO, so sieht's
aus, hab ich das auf dem Desktop, ne, oder, aber ich hab, ich hab Free-Chart-Launcher
auf dem Desktop, oder wie kommst du jetzt drauf, Amorphium, wie kommst du jetzt grad
auf Dark, das würd mich interessieren, ach, auf, auf E, jaja, stimmt, da hab ich, da
hab ich den, den Ordner liegen, tatsächlich, ja, du hast recht, chat blickt wieder mehr
durch auf meinem Rechner als ich, so, arch, by the way, weiter, Prozessoren, ne, ja, vier,
oder, bam, ne, ein CPU, vier Kerne, 16G RAM, irgendwo hin muss ich mit meinem 32G, Bridge
Networking, jawoll, jawoll, Create New Disk, 128G wieder, bam, Single Disk, next, Arch
by the way, VMDK, next, so, das einzige was ich immer mache ist, Drücker raus, Soundkarte,
Soundkarte können wir drin lassen, Display, 3D Acceleration, man weiß ja nie immer einstellen,
vielleicht wollen wir irgendwie zumindest ein bisschen Transparenz oder so machen, und
jetzt stellen wir das ganze noch auf EFI Boot um, jaja, machen wir auch, ach so, nested Virtualisierung
muss sein, ich kann mir immer nicht merken was ich da einschalten muss, ich glaub das
da, falls wir irgendwie da drin immer was, nested Virtualisierung einschalten, bei meinem,
bei meinem Basteltrieb ist nie verkehrt, so, Arch by the way, da sind wir, Options, so,
Advanced UEFI Boot, so, und ansonsten glaub ich muss man nix großartig machen, es wird
wahrscheinlich einiges mit Wayland nicht gehen, ich finde bei Wayland sieht man so den, den
großen Vorteil und Nachteil so quasi von Wobbly Wind aus Beste, so von, von der ganzen,
ja man kann nicht sagen Linux Entwicklung, das trifft's ja nicht, von diesem ganzen
Linux Ökosystem, von der Ursprungsidee her war ja mal, X ist so alt und so unwahrtbar
und so painst jam, dass das keiner machen will und deswegen machen wir jetzt Wayland
und wir machen was neues, das Problem ist nur, dass die mittlerweile in Wayland so viel
Zeug beachten müssen, dass es wahrscheinlich auch genauso abfuck ist wie X, da was drin
zu machen und jetzt auch keiner mehr Bock hat, ja ich aktualisier dann auch meine, meine
GitHub-Config, i3-gaps, i3-gaps aber, i3-gaps, beste Flow, danke für den Sub, so, also Arch
by the Way, anschalten, I'm finished Installing, natürlich, so, also Arch Linux Install Medium,
Comfy, mit Sprache, dass es für nicht Cortana Style sein, oder, Copy to RAM, naja, wir haben
genug RAM, aber ich nehm einfach das Standard Ding, so, wie gesagt Leute, ich habe noch
nie, auch wenn ich schon seit Jahren Archbase Linux verwende, noch nie ein Arch by the
Way, so richtig raw von Hand selbst installiert, das höchste der Gefühle war Manjaro Architekt,
Matt, warum ist Way größer i3, ok, Installation Guide can be accessed via, Installation Guide,
boah, Lynx Reader, vermute ich mal, Arch Wiki by the Way, ok, erste Mal, Stretch, so, das
muss erstmal schön hässlich aussehen, ja, die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, mach einfach
Arch Install eingeben, bam, ohje, jetzt geht's los, also, Select Arch Install Language, Sekunde,
ich mach mal den Stretch ein bisschen anders, so, da sieht das nämlich schon er aus, Englisch,
Keyboard Layout, DE, SELECT MIRROR REGION, DE, da kann man mehrere auswählen, ja, dann
nehmen wir Germany, ABCDEF, wo ist Frankreich, ach da, Frankreich ist halt auch immer ganz
gute Mirrors, reicht, ok, ESCAPE, Moment, ah, ohje, jetzt hab ich's verkackt, ESCAPE,
ok, weiter, Germany, Frankreich, und jetzt ENTER, ah, ENTER muss man drücken, ok, SELECT
START DRIVES, äh, das da ist die Festplatte, geh ich mal von aus, das da unten drunter
ist das CD-Laufwerk, DISK LAYOUT, WIPE ALL SELECTED DRIVES AND USE A BEST FV DEFAULT
PARTITION LAYOUT, mal gucken, mal gucken was der macht danach, would you like to use, no,
no, no, ENCRYPTION PASSWORD, brauchen wir nicht, DEF SDR, WIPE TRUE PARTITION, schau
wir mal, schau wir mal, SYSTEM DE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO USE CRUB AS, no, ich hab kein BTRFS,
ich hab EXT4, wie kommst du da drauf, dass ich BTRFS ausgewählt hätte, oder, hab ich
mich verdrückt, wollte eigentlich EXT4 auswählen, guck mal mal, ja EXT4 hab ich doch gemacht,
NEW SWAP, LEUDE, ich habe 16G RAM, da brauchen wir kein SWAP, SWAP IS OVERRATED, GEBATED,
OUTDATED, das brauchen wir nicht, FLOATED, is das, SPECIFY HOUSE NAME, ARCH BY THE WAY,
ROOT PASSWORD, nö, brauchen wir nicht, wir machen, wir machen SUDO, SUDO STELLS, ok,
ich muss jetzt mal kurz durchlesen, was finde man ist, einfach als BTRF um Fenster, hm,
ja gut, das liegt da wahrscheinlich eher an Wayland, nicht ans Way, ja und das letzte
mal ist halt das Problem gewesen, was ich unter Wayland hatte, zum Beispiel dass das
RE-SIZEN von Gtk, also von meinem Gnome Terminal zum Beispiel nicht richtig funktioniert hat
und sowas, das ist aber auch schon wieder 3-4 Jahre her, muss ich sagen, aber seitdem
habe ich mir gedacht ganz ehrlich warum soll ich da irgendwas anderes benutzen
der kram funktioniert ja specify super user account max password 123456
was leute das kann also jetzt mal ernsthaft das ist best practice password
das ist alles mit das weit verbreitetste password auf der welt das kann nicht
schlecht sein yes ich bin sure 123456
jawoll
confirm and exit mehr user accounts brauchen wir nicht
ja das kann ich dir erklären warum ich das mache
der hauptgrund ist dass das man jarro das architekt iso eingestellt hat
und dass man manchmal mit gewissen repos probleme unter man da war weil die zwei
wochen hinten dran sind und ich eh nicht so genau weiß was die
letzterzeit treiben und weil ich immer wieder neu installieren wollte einfach
mal ein bisschen auf ich habe da so viel so viel krempel mittlerweile am start
das ist natürlich nicht so schlimm wie unter windows aber manchmal fällt
einem dabei auf dass es neue sachen gibt die besser sind als das was man gerade
hat so also specify user account brauche ich specify profile äh was kann man da
auswählen desktop ne ne ne ne minimal very basic in
sei aus du customise as you see fit korrekt katschi bass ich meine wir
könnten auch minimal x org ich glaube wir installieren minimal x org weil das
brauche ich eh für i3 so mw open source treiber das ist der offizielle art
installer
mach mal zwei ok vielleicht vielleicht ich schreibe mir das mal auf
vielleicht vielleicht
das desktop profil kann i3 ja aber das ist also ein komischer
vorkonfigurierter i3 das gefällt mir nicht das soll nackig sein ich will da
nichts vor installet kriegen
das mit zwei und weil das kann man vielleicht danach mal ausprobieren
ja wir werden gleich sehen ob der was taugte art installer so audio brauche
nicht oder i wire das ist bei wire moment
linux pipe wire
ok ich installiere einfach mal just von pipe wire ich habe keine ahnung ob das
funktioniert select kernels linux ja kein lts lts jebaited outdated additional
packages
hart hop
kann man danach dann suchen oder was
ne
ok base devil brauche auf jeden fall
und was kommers separated oder was das kann ich doch j brauche man kommen oder
space separated sudo ist vielleicht auch verkehrt
wobei sudo sollte eigentlich sollte eigentlich dabei sein wenn ich einen
super user habe das gucken wir jetzt gleich mal
wir machen jetzt bei der stelle gerade mal einen snapshot einfach nur mal
nur mal sicher zu gehen
also
ja gut gucken wir mal na geil ach das ist nicht dabei ja dann wir dann müssen
wir später installieren das können wir dann können wir dann nach jetzt ist
passt schon so ein package kommt mal bevor es gibt dann installieren wir nix
richtig so also konfigure network was war mal da no network copy iso network
konferenz use network manager war ja der cp
es war jetzt der cp
Ich glaube die Omas heutzutage denken sich da gar nichts dabei, select timezone, ne wir
sind in Europe, achso mit slash, oder kann man direkt Berlin suchen, na mal mit was machen
die, mit was machen die dieses select Menü, das sieht ein bisschen wie FZF, äh FZF aus,
would you like to automatically synchronize time, yes, additional repositories to enable,
ok, ich glaube das wars, muss ich jetzt save configuration oder install machen, was ist
das für eine Distro, das ist Arch by the way, das ist das originale, das einzige, keine
forks und abkömmliche, einfach install, ok, ja, ok alles klar, oh mit countdown, monkaS,
Festplatte wird formatiert, das ist der offizielle installer, ja den gibt es noch nicht so lang,
den gibt es erst seit einem Jahr oder so, der macht wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger
das gleiche wie hier der installation guide von hand, ja 5.17 sind wir schon, und der
neue kernel, der dauert auch nicht mehr lange, der, ähm, da war letztens erst die beta version,
der müsste eigentlich, also 5.18 müsste bald da sein, linux 5.18, vor 5 stunden linux
5.18 ist da, ok, gut dass wir drüber gesprochen haben, ja, reisefs wurde entfernt, ja, das
kann ich verstehen, ah ne, deprecated, reisefs, das ist das filesystem von dem typ, der seine
frau umgebracht hat und jetzt im knast sitzt, das möchte keiner mehr maintainen, zwei patches
a healer, gut, ex fat, warum ist das toss, der typ ist rechtskräftig verurteilt, das
ist so, der hat seine frau umgebracht, und hat halt zufälligerweise noch ein linux filesystem
entwickelt, nur jetzt sitzt der im knast, und so wie es aussieht auch zurecht, doch
für cef konnte nach zweieriger arbeit, xfs, bedrifts, leute wie sprecht ihr das aus, ich
weiß nicht, ok, der chat ist sich auch nicht so ganz einig, ja, oh guck mal, der linux
scandaler ist jetzt c2011 standard, ok, hält sich ein grenzen, achso, das ist schon fertig,
der installer ging aber schnell, would you like to change root into newly created installation
perform post install configurations, no, einfach booten und gut ist, reboot, nee nicht reboot,
power off, debated und wieder löschen, oh, nee nee ich leuchte das nicht, quatsch, ich
hänge bloß die cd aus, ich stelle das cd auf, weil er auf not connected, also ganz
ehrlich, ich krieg immer anfälle, gerade wenn ich auf der arbeit, guck mal hier, wie clean
das booten jetzt aussieht, wenn ich auf der arbeit größere jam updates machen muss, wobei
es ist, alter, was ist das für ein bootgeschwindigkeit, lol, ok, da ist ja auch nichts drauf, muss
ich mir auch mal dazu sagen, da ist ja überhaupt nichts drauf, das ist systemd boot ctl, so,
was wollte ich jetzt sagen, ich krieg immer anfälle, wenn ich auf der arbeit jam update
machen muss, bzw. dnf update ist ja glaube ich mittlerweile unter centos, wobei centos
gibt es ja auch immer unter redhead basierten sachen, das rötelt immer ewig rum und pacman
bamm installiert, fertig, ok, also einloggen, maxedarch by the way, guck mal, tastatur layout
stimmt, wir können root werden, pacman, minus, boah, ist das für mal für updaten, kann
ich auch aus dem kopf immer nicht merken, so, wie installiert man denn jetzt, install
jarch, archwiki, schon ewig her, dass ich das gemacht hab, so, written in go, wisst
ihr was ich witzig finde, es gibt zwei programmiersprachen, nämlich rust und go, wo die leute, wo die
leute, dabei schreiben müssen, immer written in go, written in rust, letztendlich ist doch
scheißegal, in welcher sprache das tool programmiert ist, ich kenne keine andere sprachen, die
das so exzessiv machen wie rust und go, so als wäre rein, die sprache in der das programmiert
ist schon ein qualitätsmerkmal an sich, ok, also wie installiert man den cramplails, ich
hab das auch schon gemacht, also ist nicht so, dass ich da jetzt, aber das ist schon ewig
her, keine ahnung, ok install, wie geht das, installation, was paru, warum gibt es da schon
wieder 3000 verschiedene sachen, peachart, ok leute, was ist besser, j oder, also vor
allem, warum gibt es da schon wieder 3000 verschiedene sachen, ok das ist auch in go
programmiert, nur dass die nicht schreiben written in go, das finde ich schon mal persönlich
relativ, ah ne, das ist rust, haben die written in rust hier drin stehen, ja zum glück nicht,
rust oder go, entscheide mich, installation, clone, einfach clone und gut ist, ok, j hat
einen buchstaben weniger, das ist ein gut, das ist tatsächlich eine gute, ok, ok, verses,
ok wir lesen uns mal durch, was sagt denn archlinux reddit dazu, silvercross, danke für den
ab, i use j, yay, yay, muss man wahrscheinlich sagen, nicht j, wie soll man das aussprechen,
it has a happier name, ich hab auch seit jahren j, yay oder, ich weiß gar nicht wie man das
ausspricht, wie spricht man das jetzt eigentlich aus, schreiben die das irgendwie, yay, rust
by the way, zainer defaults, also im prinzip
so wie ich das verstehe, ist es eigentlich total egal, eigentlich scheint es total wurscht
zu sein, ok, wie installiert man das denn, source, ne, binary, wie installiert man das
denn jetzt am besten, ok, was sagen die hier dazu, installen, die sagen einfach, ok, die
sind beides das gleiche im endeffekt, also es ist schon ewig her, dass ich das letzte
mal gemacht hab, bloß, erstmal 3 stunden compile, ne, das geht schnell, installierst
es am besten from source, aber das kann sich dann schon selbst updaten, oder, ok, also,
ah ne, ich kann ja gar nicht copypasten jetzt, by the way, arch by the way, ok, dann easy,
you can chain the commands, ne, ne, ne, ne, das war mal schön nachher, ne, ne, ne, ne,
also, so, wollen wir mal hier gucken, also was muss man jetzt machen, kurz, so, dass ich
was seh. So. Also. Zack. I. Onkar. Äh. So. Also. Das muss man tippen, weil ich hab
kein Copy Paste. Also. Pac-Man minus S. Knee. Dirt. Git. Base. Das haben wir wahrscheinlich
schon drauf, aber ob wir Shit drauf haben, weiß ich nicht. Pearl? Ja gut, Git braucht
Pearl gedünst. Das hat manche Pearlscripts noch dabei. Weil. Weil uralt Zeugs. Pearl.
So. Uuuh. PC Speaker muss gleich aus. Da krieg ich Anfälle. Git. Clone. Our. Archlinux.org.
Git. CD. Make. PKG. Minus SE. Achso. Ja ok. Dann. Dann halt nicht. Warum muss ich
das jetzt noch. Ok, passt mal auf Leute. Fiveheader Time. Richtig Fiveheader Time.
Ähm. Bash History. Bash History kopieren. Nach Home. Max. Bash. History. Hab ich gar
nicht. So. Home. Max. Und jetzt. Chown. Chown. Max. Max. Bash History. So und jetzt
ausloggen. Und wieder einloggen. Und jetzt hab ich meine Befehle von vorhin wieder. Haha.
Outplayed. Alter. Outplayed. M. Make. PKG. Minus SE. Ah jetzt muss ich. Moment warum
darf ich das nicht als Root machen, wenn ich schon immer ein Root Passwort brauch. Ja
PC Speaker muss raus. Alter. Yes. Go. Erstmal Go installen. The Go by the way. Doch ich
hab Sudo. Sonst könnt ihr das wahrscheinlich gar nicht hier nachfragen jetzt. PC Speaker.
Ich mach gleich Modprobe. Wir machen die Hardcore Variante. Modprobe minus R. PC Speaker. Fake
Root. Yes. Ok. Sudo. Das passt mal auf. Wir machen jetzt die gewaltsame Variante. Modprobe
minus R. PC Speaker. PC Speaker. Haha. Und schon tut es nicht mehr. Erstmal PC Speaker
remove. Ok und jetzt können wir wahrscheinlich. Updaten und so. Tatsächlich. Nice. Funktioniert.
So und jetzt können wir ins i3 Gaps. Weil die coolen Leute verwenden i3 Gaps. Manch
einer wird jetzt vielleicht sagen. Gaps machen keinen Unterschied. Aber Gaps ist beste. Guck
an was es da sonst noch so gibt. Yes. Not Sway by the way. Das probieren wir nachher mal
aus. Was einfach so i3. Nee. Start x i3. Moment ich muss mal mein anderes Stilungs anmachen
meinen Startscript angucken. Weil ich keine Ahnung mehr hab wie man das eigentlich korrekterweise
macht. Arch by the way. War das so. Ja das war glaube ich tatsächlich so. Wartet mal.
Was ist denn da für Dinger. Einfach i3 am Ende reinschreiben. Ok easy.
War das so. Wie. Can't wait. Nicht übertreiben. Wim. Achso wir sind im falschen Verzeichnis.
Wim x init rc i3. Ups. Warum hab ich mich ausgelockt. Aha. Gut was auch immer. Start
x. Was. All right alles klar. Der font fehlt ja das sieht tatsächlich so aus. Alles klar
alles klar. Ich hab auch kein Terminal installiert und nix ich glaube ich muss gerade noch mal
raus. Was war das x die exit. Fuck. Moment wir switchen jetzt einfach aufs zweite oder
aufs dritte Terminal oder aufs vierte Terminal. Und installieren. Was hatten da standardmäßig
eingestellt. I3. Konfig i3. Noch gar nix. Macht der Standardmisch x Term oder so dass
der irgendein Terminal drin aufmachen kann. Ich mein ich will mir ehrlich gesagt kein
x Termin installieren. Terminal. Komm ich installiert jetzt ich installiert testweise
mal ein x Term. Einfach weil das auf jeden Fall funktioniert. Ok wir können auch andere
Terminals installieren wenn ihr wollt. Alla kriti bestes. Warum. Warum ist das bestes
Chat. Ich muss jetzt hier irgendwas klicken das überfordert mich jetzt weil ich seh
nicht was ich was ich brauche. Ok welche fonts muss ich denn installieren. Dafür dass das
jetzt funktioniert. Ein Open GL Terminal. I3 install arch by the way. Ok also. Key bindings
Containers Fonts. Ja welche Fonts muss ich denn installieren dass das jetzt funktioniert.
Iken Fonts. Ja wohl eher nicht. Das ist so minimal dass da nicht mal Schriftarten dabei
sind. Das ist natürlich auch geil. Fonts. Was sind da so die Default Fonts. Alles klar.
Was install. I3 Default. No Fonts. Was muss man da installieren. Wir können Dings installieren.
Wie heißt das. Wie heißt das Ding. Nee nee. Das ist ein Plane Arch. Ja. Wie heißt
der. Wie heißt der Kram nochmal. Xorg Fonts. Das sind die können wir. Das sind aber die
hässlichen. Wir haben sogar installiert schon. Wie heißt das das was ich standardmäßig
immer genommen habe. Keine Ahnung ich Reboot mal kurz. Vielleicht geht es ja jetzt. Also
die Xorg Fonts sollten wir eigentlich standardmäßig schon. Laufen die Guest Addons schon. Nee
die Guest Addons sind noch nicht drauf. Start X. Was installierst du so. Naja das sollte
am Ende wieder ungefähr so ausschauen wie mein anderer Kram. So der Spur nach. Ich
werde auch einiges rüber kopieren. Ich werde das jetzt nicht komplett neu machen mit. Ok
also das hat keine Fonts. Das ist outdated. Gibt es nicht. Keine Fonts. Ok das ist natürlich
äußerst blöde wenn es keine Fonts gibt. Also wir gehen mal auf die andere Konsole. Also
ok was installieren wir denn jetzt. Vielleicht sind noch nicht. Dann installieren wir doch
Xorg Fonts. Standard Gedöns. Ach so Moment. Xorg Fonts. Xorg Fonts. Kyrillic. Nee nee.
Hackman minus S. Hat der Auto complete? Nein. PC Speaker ist wieder da. MonkaS. Mod. Modprop
PC Speaker. Viel besser. Arch Xorg. Gibt es doch. Ok. Fonts. Fonts. File is a. Ok.
Hackman minus S. Xorg. Ok der installiert Gedöns was ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht
brauchen. Hier Xorg Fonts installiert der aber alles mit. Alles klar. Gib ihm. Gib
ihm. So. So wie kommt man nochmal raus. Control. Alt. Back. Nee. Ah doch. Doch. Ok. Ich hab
es noch im Kopf. Start. X haben wir jetzt Fonts. Immer noch keine Fonts. Dann weiß
ich auch nicht. Dann müssen wir googeln. X. E3 no Fonts. E3 missing Fonts. E3 does
not display any characters. Alles klar. Die E3 config macht man normalerweise beim Start
beim ersten Mal. Du machst den Start und dann fragt er dich ob du die default config
anlesen willst. Here some tips. Hackman. Ja aber. Das. Irgendwelche random Fonts werden
es ja nicht sein. Ok das funktioniert schon mal. E3 doesn't work with Xorg Fonts. Sieht
so aus. Ja so ungefähr sieht es bei mir auch aus. Wie weit bist du schon. Ich hab. Ich
kann den Desktop starten aber er hat keine Bilder. Ok. Ok das heißt ich muss irgendwelche
True Type Dinger installieren. Ok na dann. But why. Knu Free Fonts. Die sehen bestimmt
abvergesslich aus. Fünf habe ich immer gehabt. Das war ganz brauchbar. Und Hack. Hack muss
auch sein. Beste. Wir wissen ja auch nicht. Wir wissen ja auch das es nicht Linux ist.
Es ist Knu Linux. Haha wir haben Fonts. Pock. Also. You have not configured E3. Ja ich weiß
Generate Standard Config. Yes. Kannste machen. Windows Default Modify. Ich überschreibe das
eh mit meiner. Mit meiner Config dann. Ich kann wahrscheinlich schon ein Terminal starten
ja. Default Modify. Windows. Yes. Ok Bam. Zack. Idiot. Das ist ein Xterm. MonkaS. E3
Profile. Zeig mal was machen die denn. E3 Lock. E3 Start. E3 Block. X. Ok da hätte
er fast das gleiche gemacht. Ah das Standard D-Menü ist auch dabei. Ok viel viel Unterschied
hat er jetzt auch nicht gemacht oder. Ja ja ich installiere auch kein D-Menü. Rofi ist
das beste. Das habe ich auch sonst immer. So erst einmal. Moment. Erstmal. Gnome Terminal.
Ich brauche erst einmal meinen gescheiten Terminal Emulator weil ansonsten kriege ich.
Anfälle. So es gibt Gnome Terminal oder Gnome Terminal mit Backquar oder Gnome Terminal
mit Fedora Patches. Ganz normales Gnome Terminal. Cellphone Morin. Lange nichts gesehen von dir
hier. Es ist ganz schön lange her. Kannst dich noch hier. Kannst dich noch an das Bild
erinnern. Das wird immer noch witzigerweise. Wird das nicht mehr. Warte mal. ReLive. Es
wird immer noch hier. Du wirst immer noch im Sessel sitzen gefunden. Wenn man nach Max
FPS ReLive sucht. Das ist eigentlich da bescheuert. Das ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen dich da
von hinten im Stuhl zeigt. Man weiß nicht warum aber. Ja warum nicht ja. Ja ich verstehe
es auch nicht. Ok Gnome Terminal mag nicht starten aus irgendwelchen Gründen die ich
nicht verstehe. Gnome Terminal hat kein Bock wie es aussieht. Kegwaid. Warum nicht. Warum
nicht. Gute. Der Scheiß Gnome. Ok was habt ihr gesagt ist das andere Terminal was viel
geiler ist. So. Weil ihr side chat. Ok das startet. Warum auch immer. Ich brauche erstmal
irgendwie halbwegs funktionsfähig. War das nicht I3. I3 menu. Wie ist der Krampel. Da
können wir einfach hier mal abgucken. Ah ne einfach so demenu. Ok. Das werden wir dann
wieder runterschmeißen. Ich will einfach was was mit der default config funktioniert.
Was richtig schreibt dann gibt es auch. Gibt es auch. Gnome Terminal ist doch gar nicht
scheiße. Demenu da. Da ist es jetzt kann man starten. Gut zack. Standardmäßiges dark theme
Terminal das finde ich schon mal. Ok warum kann man hier nichts copy paste mit rechts
klick das irritiert mich schon mal ganz stark. Und das snappt auch nicht hier so ran. Beim
copy paste das irritiert mich auch. So jetzt müssen wir erstmal gnome. Jetzt müssen wir
erstmal die vm tools installieren. Open vm tools. Das da. Damit wir endlich fullscreen
bekommen und es nicht mehr wie Augenkrebs aussieht. Vmware. User. Das da. Ne. Ach wie
war das noch mal. System. CTL. Start. Vm. Tools. Oder so. Tatsächlich. Also wie ich
es einfach nur auswendig weiß. Vm tools de enable. Sehr schön. Kann man ja Schriftgröße
machen. Gut. So ok wie konfiguriert man dieses Terminal. Hat das eine config. Config Datei.
Massive file header. Ok wir brauchen einen Browser Firefox. Und es ist glücklicherweise
kein Ubuntu wo wir jetzt erstmal snap installieren müssten. Kann man nicht einfach da pack
man minus s Firefox. Doch bam. So wir brauchen einen Browser. Snap alter snap ist absolut
pains champ Erfindung. Gut so Firefox. Nice Leute. Wir haben einen Terminal und wir haben
einen Browser. Damit kann man doch schon mal was anfangen. Was muss man standardmäßig
machen zum updaten das oder. So. Oder so. Ne so muss man machen. Dass man auch Git
repos mit mit updaten. So ok GitHub. Vielleicht vielleicht finde ich das ja doch gar nicht
so. Ok ich brauche definitiv ordentliche Fonts. Guckt euch das mal an. Wie das ausschaut.
Nice font ja. Top. Top. Das sieht aber hardcore beschissen aus. Also wie konfiguriert man
den Kram denn. Konfiguration. Gibt es standardmäßig nicht. Ok. Konfig. Haben die vielleicht
irgendeine. Beispiel config oder so. Ok chat. Chat. Was. Was. Was habt ihr denn gegen
das Terminal. Mal ganz einfach abgesehen. Das ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht funktioniert
ich genau weiß warum warum. Ganz wichtig geht dann Copy Paste. Geht Copy Paste. Nein. Copy
Paste geht nicht. Und ich vergesse immer wieder was man machen muss damit Copy Paste geht.
Man muss damit Copy Paste in die FM geht. Man muss irgendeine total wirre Library installieren
dass es funktioniert. Also hier geht es geht ja ja hier drinne geht das. Aber das geht
nicht raus. Das sind auch das hat mit den vm Settings nichts zu tun. Man musste irgendeine
total wirre Library installieren die ich immer vergesse. Echt Knoom Termin. Knoom Termin
ist discontinued. Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Wann war Toolzins installiert.
Knoom Console. Was. Och nee oder. Was ist denn Knoom Console. Ok. Warum auch immer
aber das gibt es schon mal nicht als normales Package das fällt schon mal raus. Nee. Kitty
gibt es auch noch. Ok. Kitty Terminal Github. Ich verwende seit Jahren schon Knoom Terminal
warum ist das auf einmal Deprecated. Was ist mit euch los. Ok. Und das ist das ist auch
fast feature rich cross Plattform Gp. Was. Was hatte meine Grafikkarte mit meinem Terminal
zu tun. Ja ok das Fenster Rendern im Endeffekt aber ich wusste gar nicht dass mein Terminal
irgendwie durch meine Grafik Ausgabe beschränkt wird in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Wie hast
das andere Github. Ok. Ich bin jetzt Kitty auch noch. Ja mach ich geb ihm. Kitty. Rechts
Klick Menüs sind outdated overrated oder. Nee Konsole ist passt gefällt mir nicht. Warum
habe ich kein rechts Klick Menü ich bin da so dran gewöhnt rechts Klick und auf Kopieren
zu gehen. Ich mag auch Knoom Terminal aber irgendwie ist Knoom Terminal anscheinend outdated
das verwenden die coolen Leute nicht mehr. Aber viel wichtiger wir müssen Copy Paste
hinkriegen. Was war das noch mal. Das muss ich nach Art Schwicky Copy Paste. Das war.
Irgendein. Irgendeine Library die ich immer vergesse die müssen wir installieren. Copy
Paste. Ok. Copy und Paste. Ach das da genau. Das musste man installieren. Das kann sich
doch kein Mensch merken. Ok. Deswegen steht es auf der Wiki Seite könnte man jetzt sagen.
Gtk mm. Warum. Und welches davon das da. Oder das da. Oder das da. Ich installiere einfach
beides alles. Gtk 3 Gta 2 und Gtk 5. Alles drauf. Amok aus. Sos. Extrem. Sos oder Sass
wenn man der Tagesschau glaubt. Und warum. Ein Parody OS. Alles klar. So darf ich jetzt
Copy und Paste. Ist das jetzt möglich. Wahrscheinlich muss ich Rebooten dass ich Copy Paste darf.
Wieso glauben Linus Entwickler dass man keine Desktop Icons braucht. Wozu man dann braucht
man einen Desktop. Ich habe keinen Desktop unter Linus. Ich verwende ich verwende kein
Desktop. Ich verwende nur Fenster im Fullscreen also guck ich habe keinen Desktop. So. Copy
Paste. Es geht immer noch nicht. Ok. Forever user. Geht es jetzt. Jetzt geht es. Ok das
muss gestartet werden. Was haben die dazu geschrieben in der. And sure etc. Exist and
if not running. Ok. Gucken wir mal ob das existet. Ja das existet. Aber das wird mein
X in it als CD ausführen wahrscheinlich. Wie habe ich denn das hier bei meinem anderen
gelöst. Nach zwei Sekunden einfach starten. Five header. So mache ich das auch weiterhin.
Null. Das ist glaube ich die unschönste Variante aber die funktioniert. Five header move ja.
Deep Forever user. Und dann Wallpaper. Wallpaper ist ganz wichtig Leute. Ohne Wallpaper geht
nichts. Das ist das. Das ist das was wir als nächstes machen müssen. Wallpaper. Ok also
mk dir Repos. Und jetzt muss ich mal auf mein GitHub GitHub wo Blots. Und mir mal. Mein
dort Fall Repo aus checken. Oder nur nur komm wir machen das mal nur nur das Skript. Reicht.
Es war mal ursprünglich ein eigenes Repo. Aber egal. Was. Kein W. Get. W. Get. W ist
so das un intuitivste was es gibt. Am englischen. Wer kommt auf so eine Idee. Sie haben heute
gibt es nicht. Get Wallpaper. Failed. B ist nicht installiert. Ok. So kann man sich auch
daran rumhangeln was man so alles braucht. Achtung Wallpaper. Zag. Wallp... Curl. Curl
brauchen wir auch noch. Curl brauchen wir auch noch. So. Hardtop brauchen wir noch.
Wobei letztens bei mir auf der Arbeit meinte einer B-Top ist der eigentliche der neueste
Shit. Also ich ich gucke ja immer mit Hardtop ja. Aber letztens auf der Arbeit meint einer
B-Top ist viel geiler. Ok das ist 32 32 Bit True Color Anzeige Ding. Lolcat muss sein
ja. Was gibt es noch Go Top. Was Go Top gibt es auch noch. Ok und was Go Go Go Top. Wie
viele gibt es von diesem Krempel eigentlich. Warum gibt es davon eigentlich 30 Milliarden
Dinger. Go Top. Ok. Go Top. Go Top. Hard Why. Ganz ehrlich ich werde wahrscheinlich
bei Hardtop bleiben. Da habe ich mich dran gewöhnt. Was in Node.js ist ja noch schlimmer.
Guckt euch das mal an. Das hat als Abhängigkeit einfach Node installiert. Ja Self-Own das ist
nicht für jeden was. Das ist Five Head Hacker Man Content. Wie geht es dir eigentlich. Lange
nicht gesehen. Ich habe gar nicht mitgekriegt dass du noch da bist. Alles ok. So schnell
wer. Ja das muss. Was End Top gibt es auch noch. Ne End Top. Ach Network Traffic. Ja
ok. Gut. Also das muss das muss weg. Je Top muss wieder weg. C-Ares. Zwei Mal Corona hattest
du nicht schlecht. Ich hatte noch nicht einmal Corona. Ich halte ja auch Abstand immer.
Ob er sagt man so ich weiß nicht dass ich Corona hatte. Vielleicht hatte ich es ja und
es war so mild dass ich nichts gemerkt habe davon. Aber doppelt Corona ist natürlich
auch nichts schönes. Als nächstes haben wir eh dann wieder Affen Affen Pocken oder
so was es jetzt gibt. Quarantäne Fakt ab. Ja das kann ich mir vorstellen. Wir erstmal
kurz die Schrifte ein bisschen größer machen. Leute ich muss mich mal kurz konzentrieren.
Was müssen wir jetzt sinnvolles machen. Es gibt 30.000 Sachen die noch eingerichtet
werden müssen. Beschreibt gerade einer per Teams von der Arbeit an. Gude. Da antworte
ich jetzt nicht drauf. Warum nicht mal Sway probieren. Ist doch erstmal egal. Ich brauche
doch die ganzen Sachen. Sowohl unter E3 als auch unter Sway. Ich brauche ein Terminal.
Ich brauche was ordentliches eingerichtetes. Gude. Ok was kommt als nächstes jetzt. Ok
er schreibt weiter. Gude. Bitte hier werden alte IPs entfernt da die Hosts in die Cloud
gewandert sind. Aha aha. Sehr interessant. Das wusste ich jetzt ganz ganz wichtig. Lass
mal kurz überlegen. Ok wir haben ein Hintergrund Bild. Wir haben ein Terminal und wir haben
einen Browser. So jetzt Schriftarten. Schriftarten. Also Tudus. TMAX. Haben wir auch nicht. Ich
muss meine Tudus mal aufschreiben. Kann ich. Vier. So also. Font Browser. Emoji Font.
Ganz wichtig. Ganz ganz wichtig. Ohne Emoji Font. C-Matrix. ASCII-Iquarium und LOLCAT.
Auch ganz wichtig. Muss muss. LOLCAT ist das allerwichtigste was man überhaupt installieren
kann. So. Ruby. Und ASCII-Iquarium. Jawoll. Ach Quatsch. Neo Fetches für die Posa bei
bei Unix Porn. So LOLCAT. Jetzt haben wir schonmal das wichtigste. Jetzt haben wir unser
Aquarium in Regenburgenfarben. E3-Status. Ja das kommt dann noch alles. Das stimmt
das brauchen wir auch noch erst recht. E-Polibar wollen wir nicht. E3-Status Rust wollen wir
haben. Schreiben wir mal ins Tudu rein. Stimmt wenn wir das andere probieren. Ok weil ihr
es seid Chat ich probiere das gleich aus. Wie das mit Wayland und Sway aussieht. Kann
man das parallel installieren ohne dass sich das irgendwie breakt? So Snapshot. Erstmal
und Eliten. Ich hätte jetzt auch davon ausgegangen dass das so ist aber man weiß ja nie so genau.
Clean mal Snapshots. Sehr gut. So Gaps. Moment Leute ich muss ich muss mal Gnome Terminal
löschen. Warum habe ich eigentlich kein Auto Complete? X-Turm. Launscht er den Kram selbst?
Ah jetzt haben wir das. Ja Peacom. Stimmt brauchen wir auch noch. Natürlich brauchen
wir das für Transparenz in der Leiste um. Wie hast du dir das beigebracht? Ja ich nutze
den Kram seit 2007. Und das ist ja hier schon nicht Standard Zeug. Das ist quasi die berühmteste
Linux Distribution für Möchtegern Hacker Mans. Weil es gibt das. Ich meine Memes sind
ja in der Regel nicht lustig wenn man sie erklärt aber dem Cellphone muss ich das jetzt
mal erklären. Also das ist Arch Linux. Und es gibt so ein ungesprochenes Gesetz das jeder
der Arch Linux verwendet jedem immer ungefähr so wie bei Veganern quasi ungefragt. Bist
du nicht auch Veganer? Ich glaube schon oder? Dass jeder immer allen anderen der Arch Linux
verwendet ungefragt mitteilen muss dass er Arch Linux verwendet. Arch by the way. Und
das ist so minimalistisch dass du alles selbst machen musst nur noch wird nur noch von Gentoo
getoppt. Ach so war das ok. Leute ich lasse mich gerade voll ablenken ok. Wofür sind wir
stehen geblieben? Fonz brauchen wir. Fonz. MS Fonz. Die braucht man leider. Wobei braucht
man die? Auf einigen Seiten braucht man die. Leute das allerwichtigste ist eigentlich bevor
ich ordentliche Fonz brauche. Auch Emoji Fonz. Moment. Ach das ist Firefox. Alter Pains
Champ Werbung. Youblog erstmal reinhauen. Firefox. Nee Quatsch bei weitem nicht. Ich
glaube die meisten hier die also viele machen gerade Fachinformatiker Ausbildung. Das weiß
ich. Aber die meisten sind auch genug Leute die keinen Plan haben. Das weiß ich. Weil
sie immer schreiben Max ich höre dir gerne zu aber ich habe keine Ahnung was du machst.
Tweemoji TTF jawoll. Die brauchen wir. Tweemoji. Moji. Tweemoji. Color. Moment. Was davon
denn jetzt eigentlich? Das muss ich bei meinem anderen Linux nachgucken. Was ich da installiert
habe. Tweemoji. Tweemoji. Normal. Nicht Color. Das ist normale. Eax Moin. Du bist ja auch
am Start. Wo kommt ihr denn alle her jetzt? Eax hast du mal reingeguckt in Overwatch 2?
Und wenn ja was sagst du? Erstmal Chrome installieren. Und weil ihr es seid machen wir das jetzt auch
mit Minus S. Could not find required. Also mache ich doch so weil ich nicht weiß wie
das Package heißt. Kein Interesse. Ja oder? Hast du eine Ahnung wie Blizzard auf die glorreiche
Idee kommt das was Overwatch 2 ist? Das was ich gesehen habe ist das was andere in irgendeinem
Season Update bringen. Also kein Schimmer. VLC brauchen wir noch. VLC. So Leute was verwendet
man denn jetzt mit Pipewire um die Lautstärke einzustellen? Ich kenne bloß den Alza Mixer.
Aber den Alza Mixer wird wahrscheinlich keiner mehr verwenden. Pipewire. Nö. Keine Ahnung.
Das Paa-Wu-Control. Mal gucken ob es jetzt vielleicht, wir checken mal ob es jetzt vielleicht
ja schon funktioniert. Mit dem Sound. Nö. Ok Chrome. Nein nicht Chrome. Chrome. Äh ja
except. Ist gut. Alter jetzt kommt der Hans Meiser man. Gehen wir fort. Es gibt Leute
ich dachte ich dachte er lebt gar nicht mehr. Warum benutzt du das anstatt Paru? Weil es
ein Buchstaben kürzer ist. Ok das mit dem Sound geht so schonmal nicht. Pulse. Ne ne
ne ne. Was was? Pipewire? Pulse? Ne. Du musst fn noch die User Service für System CTL starten.
MonkaS. System CTL Status. Pipewire? Ne. List. Units. Units. Pipewire. Ne Pipe. Gibt
es da nichts oder was? Pipewire. Ne. Ja dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Was? Wireplumber? Was für Dinger? Ach du große Scheiße man. Warum bist du? Also
das ist da wirklich wieder. Ja Pipewire Pulse ist installiert ja. Ja ja. Aus irgendwelchen
Gründen ist es auch gestartet. Ich weiß nicht wer oder was es startet aber ok anscheinend.
Ok das ist das wichtigste. Erstmal 3 Emojis. 3 Emojis müssen sein. Emoji. Yes. Weil guckt
mal in in in Chrome. In in in Chrome gehen meine Emojis nicht. Und das ist völlig indiskutabel
wenn Emojis nicht gehen. Ok Moment U-Block. U-Block. Origin. Hinzufügen. Yes. Ganze
Kackwerbung überall. Gehst du weg. Ok if you do was? If you have other Emoji-Fonts installed
but one. Ich hab keine anderen Emoji-Fonts. Ok. Chrome. Hab ich jetzt Emojis? Bam. Jawoll
jetzt ist alles gut. So muss das sein. Vollständiger Satz an Emojis. Beste. Exzellent. Exzellent.
Ich mein meine Fonts sind immer noch beschissen. Moment hat Chrome. Sag mal Chrome hat included
Fonts oder? Danke Posse. Chrome hat included Fonts weil mein Firefox sieht ziemlich broken
aus mit den Fonts. Ne die verwenden Web-Fonts. Ne ok. Alles klar meine Fonts haben sich einfach
mal von alleine gefixt. Gut. Nice. Ok dann können wir das machen was der Chat schon die
ganze Zeit von mir will. Ich soll. Ok dann müsst ihr mir aber auch sagen was ich dafür
installieren muss. Sway. Tiling Wayland Compositor. Reicht es wenn ich so installiere bringt der
Wayland mit? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ok Archwiki. Archwiki Sway. Wie läufts eigentlich ganz
gut. Hast du das Major Finale gesehen? Nope. Was ist das? Das ist Arch by the way. Also
was? Sway by case. Ok was muss man da installen? Requirements. Ok. Wunderbar. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Ich würde es gerne einfach nur installieren. Scheint hochgradig. Komplex zu sein. Ok einfach
Wayland installieren. Das da? Erstes Kapitel in Sway. Ne. Erstes Kapitel in Sway ist wenn
Wayland schon installiert ist. Echt das reicht? Ah wenn ihr das sagt. Ok ich vermute mal dass
ich mein E3 abschießen muss jetzt wieder. Und jetzt Sway? So schon mal nett. Alles
klar. Jetzt weiß ich Bescheid. Jetzt weiß ich Bescheid. Muss man das als Route starten?
Ja oder? So chat so einfach ist es schon mal nett. Das man das als Route starten muss
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Also starten wir mal wieder X. Gucken wir uns mal an wie
das funktioniert. Sway install Arch. Das da? Step by step guide. Ok. Alles klar das
brauchen wir nicht. Wheel? Was? Install Sway along Sway. Ok so einfach ist es schon mal
nett. Sway for Envir. Aha. Ok das ist natürlich schön dass es erstmal wieder 30.000 Fixes
braucht bis man das Ding überhaupt starten kann. So was macht der Guide Typ? Start Sway
Simplify? Ja genau das wird es sein. Wir haben das hier im Stream. Leute Leute ich weiß was
wir machen als Fallfelder. Ich gucke jetzt einfach bei mir nach wie ich das vor 5 Jahren
gemacht habe. Ubuntu Beta anschauen Sway WM. Ach das ist Ubuntu. Moment. Ist das irgendwie
kaputt? Was muss ich denn hier installieren? So. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Ah. Ok. Keine Ahnung. Du brauchst was? Seed? D? Ok ich sehe es schon. Das ist absoluter
6 header kram dass man das laufen lassen kann
im minimal sieht management die man
Was was will ich mit meinem sitz was
Es sieht man schmetteren ok alles klar
fd to notify readiness on alter was
polkit ne das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen ok zeigt mal her installation
haben wir gemacht wl roots was für dinger wl roots install ok habe ich habe ich
sway eil was ist denn alles den ganzen eidl management was wollen wir von
ok startling ok bevor sway can be started existen keyboard mouse collect
hat für die weiß ok sieht die brauchen war
das haben wir anscheinend schon installiert sieht die haben wir installt das ist es schon
mal net ok polkit brauchen wir noch systemd log in de moment or sieht
ok haben wir haben wir den haben wir den krempel überhaupt kurz bis ich größer
system ctl status was ist das andere ok das läuft und sieht sieht d ist anscheinend
auch geschehen sieht null ist am start alles klar ok das ist disabled das ist
disabled ok polkit geben ja was kreppt
so muss ich muss ich den sieht sieht d jetzt noch starten anscheinend ok
und jetzt alter ok simply type sway enable mache ich das wenn ich weiß dass ich das
brauche sway hey das startet was ich sehe aber nix habe ich meine maus die
gruppe habe ich nicht vergessen sollte mit polkit gehen ok nice jetzt hat sich
ne das ist meine maus hier von vom host load free desktop ja da ist so bloat
free dass sie nehmen was startet ich glaube mal ich glaube die vm ist gecrasht
na das funktioniert ja richtig klasse ok kann ich das weg ins killen jetzt
not connect zu sorgen sieht d permission denied soll ich das vielleicht bei
als root einfach ausführen was wollt ihr von mir mit x funktioniert das in der
tat ganz gut ok nochmal aber das steht doch nur wenn ich das mit polkit mache
und ich habe doch polkit ich meine ich kann mich in die gruppe adden aber das
brauche ich angeblich nicht ok ich mache das auch mal als aber user user mods in
die siehgruppe als bin ich in der siehgruppe maß gut selbst und mal gucken
ob das jetzt besser funktioniert sway nice erstklassig
und not connect socket run seed d permission denied ok rebooten ihr habt
recht bäm ja auch ein auslangen wird auch da guckt mal wie krass schnell das
reboot das ist richtig bock hier flupp flupp fertig ok sway und
das stand ja gar nicht so nicht mal eine leiste oder so
ok was hat er jetzt wieder erzählt aha das was anderes die drei status not
found decks not found xss log not found network manager not found
was ich muss sieht enable so und jetzt und jetzt
scheint auch nicht zu funktionieren da ist gg es oh ich habe nichts gesagt
aber meine tastatur geht nicht meine tastatur geht nicht leute
wait a minute der reflechten desktop nur wenn ich rüber switchen
guck mal 1234 das ist so schlecht das ist genau die gleichen probleme die ich
letzte mal hatte wo ich mir gedacht habe während zum fick verwendet sowas denn
was ist das er kriege man so ich habe jetzt auf desktop 5 geswitcht jetzt
an desktop switchen außerhalb einer von so was muss doch auch in der vm funktion ich meine es ist doch
kein das kann doch nicht sein da habe ich auch kein bock das jetzt so die bank
das wird zu blöd ok wir suchen mal nach so zwei in seien feiern wir
ganz ehrlich das gebe ich mir nicht das ist mir zu blöd modpro pizzi speaker
ok ok als kurz kommen die feilferder kommande nk grab minus a dass es das
minus a sind fünf zeilen hinten dran nachdem man es gefunden hat
drei ich dachte standardmäßig machte dachte ich mache da fünf zeilen ja gut
das ist das standard das standard von grafikkarten ding es meint es funktioniert
ja offensichtlich weil es er macht ja was aber er rief recht nur wenn ich wenn
ich den desktops wenn ich auf terminals mit kann das kann den ernst sein oder ok
ich starte das ding noch einmal mal gucken was passiert ich habe 3d für die
vm an guck mal der refreshed ist einfach nicht nur wenn ich rüber switchen wenn
ich rüber switchen auf als würde der an den neuen frame plus rendern wenn ich
was wl no hardware kursos ok jetzt jetzt kommt feifert gezeugt
probiere ich jetzt noch aus wahrscheinlich export davor gehe ich
mal voll aus oder ach nee ja ich kann es auch so machen wie du schreibst dann
gilt es halt nur dafür no hardware guck mal dass ich mich nicht verschreibt
leute kursos gleich eins sway jetzt funktioniert aber das ist doch das ist
doch hängen geblieben also was seriously aber jetzt habe ich in der
englischen tastatur die habe ich unter e3 nicht dass die tastatur deutsch das ist
richtig richtig wild oder ok aber wenigstens re seisen funktioniert mittlerweile
halbwegs gescheit
das ist das ist ja schon mal was das ging das letzte mal nett das letzte mal
resize nicht richtig funktioniert ok immerhin emoji support alles am start
park laut kies d ne wie ging das sommer
laut kies d
moment was sway ernsthaft
copy paste geht auch nicht narratur herding was exiting narratur
das ist der wahnsinn an dieses scheiß betriebssystem alles auf mich fertig
copy paste ist kaputt ich kann nicht mal copy pasten ok also weil ich vor immer
user jetzt nicht gestartet habe weil das mein x in ich oh gott lull dass ja das
denung des tops ist am start jetzt funktioniert copy pastes an sich das
geht in wehland gar nicht das ist komplett broken ist der narratur der
narratur ich weiß gar nicht wie ich den narratur überhaupt gestartet hab wie
startet man den narratur
narratur dialog ok button alt und o heads up narratur keyboard rang es wie
verabschiedet sein narratur keyboard
plus ein stweiß to learn more press control und windows logo key und n to open
your narratur settings in texas online user guide ok schön turn off exiting
narratur artur ist aus
ok das lässt sich nach fremde verwenden ich kann ich kann nicht mal ich kann
nicht mal copy pasten sway forever copy paste copy pastes not working in wl
root based window manner just ok ich sehe es ist komplett useless aktuell in einer
vm den kram zu verwenden ich meine als wäre jetzt linux in der vm verwenden so
ein abgedrehte anwendungszweck ja ok nicht möglich kann man kann man
vergessen kann man eigentlich ich will nicht wieder den narratur anmachen
so das werden wir jetzt einfach mal ganz still und heimlich wieder an installen
und ich hoffe der narratur lässt mich jetzt in ruhe get wallpaper
ach ich kacke nupt ich habe ein big image of the day muss sein narratur ok also
was minus er warum habe ich kein auto complete moment was habe ich nur für
ne schelle ist es bash da können wir jetzt was ausprobieren leute
kann man das ganze eigentlich aus auch in einem docker container baut das ist
eine gute frage du kannst theoretisch auch x in einem docker container starten
ja das geht da musst du wahrscheinlich irgendwie
irgendwelche grafik devices durchreichen dass das würde theoretisch
funktionieren ich muss dir aber ehrlich sagen das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
ja also wisst ihr was ich gesehen habe das könnte man tatsächlich mal an der
stelle ausprobieren
und zwar getter wie ist das starship oder so
starship command mini rast by the way minimal blazing fast and infili
customise prompt for any shell das habe ich letztens in dem video gesehen deshalb
ich werde schon wieder angeschrieben von der arbeit ok hallo alles also alles wie
geplant ok gut zu wissen wie bekommt man j auto kommt j auto complete auto
complete not working ja best completion habe ich best completion drauf und
machen ein e zsh aber best completion habe ich nicht drauf ah dann ist ja
klar dass ok ist eine best completion jetzt ist die best completion da jawoll
jelly vor arbeit ist im chat das ist schon passiert ich kann mich noch
sonntags dran erinnern da war da war ich nahm jetzt nicht sagen war im chat
nach san max ruft mich mal an da habe ich mir gedacht jetzt wüsste ich ja
schon über den chat kontaktiert zwei so minus minus recursive oder wie kann man
alle dependency entfernen ich glaube so na so und was habe ich noch sieht sieht
geschiss muss weg sieht d was habe ich denn noch installiert was minus er es
nee n s c ok ich habe keine ahnung was was ist das gucken wir jetzt nach also
erst remove was ist minus n die deprecated use das brauche ich schon mal
nicht minus s ist jetzt ok was minus c gibt's net clean ah ok also quasi
das brauche man dann gar nicht hinten dran
a wl ruts sieht polkit und den ganzen müll kann ich auch noch haben mich auch
extra dafür installiert
weg nice so gut jetzt ist er jetzt ist er weg hat sich hat sich aus ausgesweht ok
dann probieren das mal mit dem prompt aus also unsere schrift im browser ist
schon mal gefixt der scroll noch ein bisschen langsam da
müssen wir gleich noch was dran machen und wir müssen 3d beschleunigung
einschalten weil sich der browser in der vm dann irgendwie weicher anfühlt
ich komme ist p.com noch das was man verwendet habe ich jetzt gemacht
ikon github light weight compositor for x 11
nähe es heute verwendet man zwei hat man ja gerade gesehen wie gut das
funktioniert das war ja richtig das brauche so gut das brauche ich
anderes mehr das stimmt schon funktioniert in vmw nicht du kannst
es starten mit einem mit einem hack quasi mit einem hack mit mit passenden
parameter aber copy paste ist nicht implementiert in wayland kannst kein
copy paste machen und wenn ich kein copy paste machen kann in vmw ist es halt
komplett unbenutzbar für mich
oh guckt euch das mal an massive hier wie
krasse fade action so moment mal kurz meine konfig von der anderen vm holen
wirklich ich schalte das auch aus ich mag das gar nicht konfig p.com konfig
paid in gleichfalls guckt mal leute ich habe nichts anderes reingeschrieben
außer paid in gleichfalls und p.com backend x render alles klar
connecte doch mit ssh in die vm da kannst du dann copy pasten
ja genau deswegen habe ich den vm mit grafischem interface weil ich mich per
ssh drinnen connecte um das dann zu copy pasten das ist sehr brauchbar so wo
kommt die konfig hin p.com konfig
das ist schön wenn du wehlen feier ich habe damit keine schmerzen mir ist
wichtig dass ich verwenden kann also ich will das weder feiern noch halten ich
will es einfach nur benutzen so im oberen das ist das falsche mein p.com
konfig wo muss die konfig hin
konfig
kann ich die ok da muss ich wahrscheinlich wirklich unter konfig p.com
und dann war das was p.com konfig oder wo konfig p.com konf ok alles klar mache
ich p.com konfig ich weiß nicht was mache ich denn hier was war das fading
gleichfalls das muss weg das ist nervig gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert hat
dass das fading jetzt weg ist kein fading mehr leute fading das disabelt
outdated overrated she baited fading so starten wir das auch einmal so kann ich
mir auch angucken ob das sinnvoll ist was ich da drin stehen habe oder nicht
nice ok gut funktioniert
die sogar relativ flott aus ist das eigentlich unterschied oder ist das
standardmäßig backend x render jetzt wird standardmäßig sein oder was haben
die was haben die denn für render backends backends experimental backends
was haben wir was haben wir zur auswahl glx ob das in der vm gescheit
funktioniert x hybrid pfeiffedder
experimental
ok das probiere jetzt mal aus glx das funktioniert auch kein problem
ja und was ist der unterschied damit jetzt keiner fühlt sich jetzt ehrlich
gesagt genauso an ja dann dann darfst du mit glx rennen dann dann ist ein bisschen
schneller open gl über die grafikkarte und gut ist
stand da nicht was von wie sync ja wenn man wie so sollte ich wie sync
probleme bekommen kann ich sehr immer noch weggauen
ok so jetzt machen wir unsere shell hübsch also ich muss sagen was mir bei
dem terminal standardmäßig schon mal ganz gut gefällt die haben einen
sinnvollen default hintergrund das mag ich schon mal da müsste ich eigentlich
gar nichts großartig ändern das finde ich das finde ich immer nice
hackfont
wobei das ist schon hackfont oder
das ist schon heck heckers
achso und und eine sache brauche ich auch noch java java trending warum gucke ich
mit trending java sachen auf github an ganz einfach weil das china chinesen
zeichen drin sind und ich dann feststelle dass ich nicht die richtige
schrifte hat installiert habe
java repos haben gerne china chinesen schriftzeichen drinne so das heißt ich
brauche jetzt noch wie heißt der graben linux asia font font art so wie heißt
der krempel displaying asian characters ich muss installieren
alter was ist das für komische es gibt so ganz speziellen namen für diese
sorte fons
ne ne die haben keine
ich brauche font mit hier das da brauche ich cjk
ok das ist echt so ein ding was man nicht wissen kann außer man kennt
erzählt uns erkläre uns was ist 168 und traurig
was auf leute prepare for huge chok aus champ
äh
verstehe ich nicht bin ich zu lauere iq für keine ahnung
ich glaube da kommt irgendwas lustiges ich verstehe es nicht
entweder chat es gibt jetzt zwei verschiedene varianten entweder sind wir
immer noch zu lau iq oder der witz ist so sehr unter dem durchschnitts chat
iku niveau dass man ihn schon nicht mehr versteht das geht immer nur in so einer
gewissen range net fons komplett warum soll ich denn so was installieren
net fons komplett komplett
moment was 3650 50 patched font ja warum denn das das ist wenn ich einfach mal
komplett mein rechner voll voll klatschen will oder wie
wobei ich von der idee nicht schlecht finde wenn jetzt irgendwelche webseiten
von roboto bis sonst was einbinden dann habe ich den kram einfach drauf
ob scheiß drauf gibt es da gibt es auch was als nicht extra
ich finde die idee einfach nie wieder fons zu installieren gar nicht schlecht
kommen installieren den kram jetzt bär yes da kann ich auch mal ein hack font
wieder deinstallieren oder weil es ist einfach dann alles drauf
ttf ich kann quasi danach kann aber wie mochi muss ich behalten oder ist wie
mochi da auch mit dabei die mochi color aber es lädt er da eigentlich alles
runter gerade ich deinstalliere jetzt wie mochi
und dann gucken wir ob das danach funktioniert mit diesem riesen package
ist der download speed so langsam nieder ist gar nicht so langsam der download
speed guck mal der hat schon der hat schon 300 dix wobei so schnell ist es
jetzt auch nicht wie groß ist denn das net fons komplett
auch ja sei es was
9G Warum braucht man den Kram überhaupt?
10G Warum braucht man den Kram überhaupt?
10G Warum braucht man man den Kram überhaupt?